about kyrie irving with his chemistry  and steve nash telling us he's in a  great  place right now and there he is with his  former  celtic teammates jaylen brown daniel  tyce  you know by the look of it hey he's  still  pretty cool with his guys there tatum  included and i'll say this about  kyrie 18th banner  and kyrie irving rekindling all  relationships  and affiliation well  if you think that there's mutual love  still between kyrie and the celtics that  picture speaks volumes  [Music]  started the night with the cleansing of  the negativity and it  proved to be positive for kyrie irving  and brooklyn and cassidy is standing by  with kevin durant  cass